[Music]
this
27 t-shirt with the words could i be
any more vaccinated is what sparked the
outrage could i be
more sorry some fans accused matthew of
using the hype around the friends
reunion
to profit from the pandemic perry first
introduced his line of friends inspired
merch back in december
as a fundraiser for the world health
organization's covid relief fund
et has learned there is no charity
component to this t-shirt sale
but the drama hasn't taken away from the
excitement of seeing
all six friends back together again i
was like
and then started crying the cost of
friends
seeing everything look exactly the same
does courtney still have her lines
written on the table
and these incredible friends that even
though i see these two
a lot i i still was just like jenny are
you trying to switch to me she's like
it was just the most emotional thing and
then today she can't stop crying so
yeah i'm gonna cry now seeing the old
set
and seeing the crew and seeing the the
old guys and
the guys one of the not old guys
[Music]
the older guy older maybe but they're
still the same friends the world fell in
love with almost 27 years ago
still goofing off and interrupting each
other's interviews shut up
over there shut up especially here
leblanc's
squawk they're making a lot of damage
that's so interesting because we kind of
thought the exact same thing
about them why would they schedule these
interviews on the same stage
that's a great question so anyway
thursday's emotional reunion show on hbo
max is a trip down memory lane with
appearances by celebs like
reese witherspoon and super fans like
cindy crawford and david beckham
but what we really want to know is where
would the friends be today
what do you think joey would be doing in
2021 he'd have ten kids
he'd be brain dead yeah brain dead in
the unemployment line
probably wouldn't be acting right i mean
he'd still be trying
why not yeah maybe you'd be what are you
saying running a garage or something
i i think that i would be uh like
you think i i was thinking maybe like a
competitive
mom her kids are probably too old and
she still wants to make sure the big
sale goes well
what about chandler and what about ross
he'd be coaching his kids soccer game
and ross would be running the museum
playing with the bones
playing with the bones
and then they get together once in a
while i don't think they live super
close together
we have such a bond from this show what
about making this series made this such
a bonding experience
that initial success of the show was
something that no one else could relate
to or or was going through except the
other five actors
so we really got close because of that
experience
we instantly it was in our dna that we
were family we were going to take care
of each other
and it was without question it's
unexplainable but
we're the most grateful women that i
know who have
been able to be a part of something like
this
[Music]